sollers
qu'est ce qu'on peut vous souhaiter de
pire en ce moment écoutez à part la mort
des gens que j'aime et ou bien le fait
que je sois latin brusquement d'une
crise cardiaque
je crois que le ski c'est le pire c'est
la disparition brutale magique terrible
de tous mes livres dans toutes les
librairies mais à l'heure actuelle
briche saab après laquelle des fous
aimeriez vous avoir le défaut que
j'aimerais avoir c'est pas peut-être
peut-être la curiosité poussé très loin
parce que je manque ou l'indiscrétion je
ne l'est pas pour les pas être animateur
de télévision par exemple il faudrait
que je me force
quelle est la qualité que vous regrettez
d'avoir je crois que ce quand même
or oui la courtoisie courtois oui
parfois il est trop philippe sont bien
élevés des fois puis oui la série n'est
ce pas oui mais c'est votre côté 18e
c'est la politesse des policiers ont à
gagner d'un cran la pelle
dans un monde de brutes la courtoisie
vraiment qu'est-ce qui vous donnerait
envie d'être trompé par une femme alors
soit qu'elles je découvre qu'elle
préfère des abbés chine
et pourquoi pas ou alors qu'elle lit en
cachette des romans d'anna gavalda est
là en quoi aimeriez-vous être beaucoup
plus mauvais j'aimerais être plus
mauvais en méchanceté je n'arrive je n'y
arrive pas écrit non non je n'y arrive
pas vraiment j'aimerais être plus
méchant c'est la même chose que pour
courtoisie et franchement là je qu'elles
sont quels sont les défauts que doit
avoir une femme pour vous séduire
là c'est dans le livre c'est une femme
est séduisante à partir du moment je
sens qu'elle est une bonne menteuse
celle et une bonne vente parce que
d'habitude
oui seulement bien étant des quand même
ces fonds lui c est ce qu elle ment bien
quelle est l'insulté qui vous a fait le
plus plaisir
on c'est un vieil article c'était au
vert violet rien de nouveau sous le
soleil ce à la map
quel est le compliment qui vous énerve
le plus quand on dit que je suis
brillant intelligent cultivé
on vous le fera plus
quel est le talent que vous n'aimeriez
pas avoir j'aimerais pas avoir le
le don de galvaniser les foules
ouais pareil pour l'instant tout va bien
même pas être ensemble
voilà par qui aimeriez-vous être détesté
eh bien je crois que je suis et je
depuis l'au delà
franchement c'est par françois
mitterrand voila voila je jouais pas je
n'aime pas du tout ça n'est pas du tout
du tout c'est à dire laurent gerra la
concurrence
lamy qui vous n'aimeriez pas avoir ben
laden allaient way en connaissez pas en
même temps seulement voilà quel est le
best-seller que vous n'auriez pas aimé
écrire alors j'aurais bien aimé toucher
l'argent de davinci code mais pas le
palais créé comment faire voilà joyau
seiler simbin vim